so as you describe in the madness of
crowds the herd-like behavior of humans
that gets us into trouble
uh
you as an individual thinker and others
listening to this how can you because
all of us are mid crowds we're
influenced by the society that's around
us by the people that's around us how
can we think independently
how can we
you know if you're
in um
in this in the soviet union at the
beginning of the 20th century
if you're
in
i don't know nazi germany
at the end of the 30s or 40s how can you
think independently um given
first of all
that it's hard to think independently
just intellectually speaking but also
that there's
it's just becomes more and more
dangerous so the incentive to think
independently
under the uncertainty uh that's usually
involved with thinking is
it i mean it's a silly thing to say but
on twitter there is a cost to be paid
for yes for going against the crowd on
any silly thing we can even talk about
you know
uh what is it will smith slapping chris
rock
you know there's a crowd that believes
that uh that was unjustified or
something i forget what the crowd
decided but i don't crowd split on that
one it's safe to have one opinion either
way okay it is right but there is this
you put it very nicely that there's
clearly a calculus here and that you can
measure on twitter in particular you can
measure kind of the crowd a sense of
where the crowd lays michael jackson
well oh boy
i don't want to uh this is not this is
not a legal discussion where i have
lawyer i don't have my lawyer
i don't even have a lawyer the man in
question is dead but i think most people
who are not just die hard fans would
concede that michael jackson had a
strange relationship with children yes
and
uh
was almost certainly beautiful
is that was that did the crowd agree on
that uh no the crowd hasn't agreed
because he's too famous and we all love
thriller
yeah we do so you said people who are
not fans i just don't know i'm a fan of
michael jackson but i think he was
almost certainly a pedophile
and
uh but i mean nobody wants to give up
dancing to bad at weddings so
uh they just kind of add it in it's fine
seriously it's it's it's your life
geniuses apply to uh bill cosby
oh that's well he wasn't he he was of
course
one of the most famous people in america
yeah but maybe he wasn't regarded as
talented
oh oh wow there's there's depth to this
oh yeah there's a genius opt out in all
cultures
there's a genius object in all cultures
look at lord byron lord byron shagged
his sister
doesn't affect his reputation in fact if
anything it kind of adds to it
but then again this kind of
war against the west
geniuses actually makes you more likely
or no to get cancelled
so if you look at the genius of thomas
jefferson
or well yes because if you haven't done
anything remarkable nobody will come
looking for you possibly obviously yeah
societal genius can get you in trouble
through life with nobody noticing be
totally harmless and then and then die
and hope you haven't used any carbon
um
uh but but you were asking about you
were asking about how to survive
the the era of social media as it were
and the crowds yeah and and there's a
very simple answer to that
don't um don't over rate the
significance of the unreal world
oh come on but this is still human
psychology because you want to fit in
there's a you want to why
because you're
you like people and you're this is why
not just like a small number of people
and ignore the rest yeah that's
that's what i do
well i mean i actually like most people
i know this isn't a general thing i
don't have detestation for most people
at all
most people like chemical i enjoy
speaking with and being with
but
um
in terms of storing your sense of
self-worth in absolute strangers big
mistake
yeah well me that's listen let's turn
into a therapy session because for me
and i think i represent some number of
population is i'm pretty self-critical
i'm looking for myself in the world and
uh there is a depth of connection with
people on the internet
i mean i i see the shallowness of it
it's shallow connection interesting i
put it this way if you um
if you became very ill tomorrow would
any of them help on the internet no no
no good that's a good test yeah it's a
good test but then at the end of the day
yeah you're right you're very close
friends with help family would help yeah
yep and perhaps that's the only thing
you can't start you can't store
um
significant amounts of of trust or
faith or belief or self-worth
in places which will not return it to
you
you